-Performing
"Face Down in the Moment"
from their album "The Future,"
please welcome back
Nathaniel Rateliff
& the Night Sweats!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ It careened and crashed ♪
♪ While the others waved ♪
♪ And you waited
in the sun so long ♪
♪ When you only wanted shade ♪
♪ Let the old men laugh ♪
♪ Let the old men say ♪
♪ That I've never done nothing ♪
♪ That wasn't
out of love, baby ♪
♪ Now the weight that you carry
seems such a heavy load ♪
♪ While you're ♪
♪ Facedown in the moment,
waiting to let go ♪
♪ Remember standing
in the light ♪
♪ Remember crawling
all the way ♪
♪ You paraded in the nighttime ♪
♪ For a clean getaway ♪
♪ You were standing
in the water ♪
♪ But only up to your knees ♪
♪ But you know
a strong current ♪
♪ Can always sweep you
off your feet ♪
♪ You were waiting
for the right time,
but it could take so long ♪
♪ While you're ♪
♪ Facedown in the moment,
waiting to let go ♪
♪ Facedown in the moment
♪ You were following the blind ♪
♪ When they stole your name ♪
♪ You were planning a way out ♪
♪ When you lost your way ♪
♪ Bent to a hunch now ♪
♪ Like a broke down show ♪
♪ Facedown in the moment,
just waiting to let go ♪
waiting to let go ♪
♪ Facedown in the moment,
♪ I keep waiting ♪
♪ You keep waiting on
the night ♪
your pain ♪
♪ And every moment
that you wait now ♪
♪ Is a moment slipped away ♪
♪ I think you're gonna have to
come out and face ♪
♪ All the fear
you can't explain ♪
♪ And all your life,
you've been facedown ♪
♪ Now it's time for you to see ♪
♪ All your life,
you've been facedown ♪
♪ Now it's time for you to see ♪
♪ All your life,
you've been facedown ♪
♪ Now it's time for you to see ♪
♪ See it ♪
♪ Facedown in the moment,
waiting to let go ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my goodness.